en su solicitud
[Aplausos]
fuerte
se hacen llamar operación de tula su
mensaje es claro los inmigrantes
irregulares estamos rodeados de
inmigrantes irregulares
si esos extranjeros tienen que hacer sus
maletas que se vayan de sudáfrica
tenemos hambre
de problema
los militantes del movimiento celebran
la inauguración de una nueva rama en
ciudad del cabo la capital legislativa
acusan a los inmigrantes de quitarle el
trabajo a los sudafricanos
mi generación lucho por una nueva
constitución que dice que tenemos
libertad de expresión tenemos derecho a
expresarnos sin luchar por nuestro país
y luchar por nuestra economía es
xenófobo pues que así sea
en johannesburgo los militantes de la
operación de tula son conocidos por sus
incursiones en los pequeños
establecimientos comerciales el barrio
de orange grove suele ser blanco
constante cuando pasamos los
comerciantes acababan de recibir una
carta pidiéndoles que despidieran a
todos los inmigrantes ilegales solo nos
entregaron la carta se fueron algunos
estaban siendo agresivos un poco más
lejos un peluquero congoleño instalado
en el país desde hace 20 años recibió la
misma misiva
estos pequeños establecimientos son para
los sudafricanos y solo para ellos ya no
queremos que sigan operando porque es
una ofensa criminal que un no
sudafricano tenga un negocio local eso
es ilegal
la carta no tiene nada ni siquiera un
sello de la policía estas son el tipo de
cosas que recibimos pero ellos a dónde
van a sacar sus fotocopias de hacer sus
compras hay muchos establecimientos
vacíos en los alrededores que pueden
alquilar para hacer lo mismo que
nosotros
la mayoría de los establecimientos
cierran temporalmente sus puertas cuando
reciben esas amenazas los más
vulnerables se esconden como dido un
zapatero con colegio que vive en
sudáfrica desde hace más de 15 años
quedó desfigurado durante los disturbios
xenófobos de 2019
desde entonces trata de pasar
desapercibido
hace un mes volvió a ser atacado por un
grupo que afirmaba ser parte de la
operación
y vinieron a golpearme buscaban no sé
qué cosa pero yo los evito porque son
mucho más que yo
eran unos 20 eso fue en el 2019
y mire aquí ya no tengo oreja estuve dos
meses en el hospital de johannesburgo
no sé por qué el gobierno los deja hacer
este tipo de cosas
guau
muchos se preguntan por qué las
autoridades de pretoria permiten que las
acciones xenófobas sigan ocurriendo el
gobierno responde que está preparando
una serie de leyes para controlar mejor
la inmigración irregular ya que ésta
estaría alimentando las tensiones
sociales se estima que hay más de 5
millones de inmigrantes en el país de
los cuales sólo 3 millones están
regularizados es muy difícil controlar
el ingreso
hoy el servicio público estaba
trabajando en la extensión de las bayas
ni siquiera tuvieron te puede construir
los kilómetros adicionales porque del
otro lado ya las habían destruido
además del control en las fronteras el
gobierno también tiene prevista una
legislación relativa al empleo una ley
de cuotas que limitaría la contratación
de extranjeros en cada sector la medida
coincide con las ideas de los
simpatizantes de la operación de tula
presentes en la audiencia pública
nos dimos cuenta durante nuestras
operaciones de que algunas empresas
contratan muchos extranjeros
50% en algunos casos y hasta 90% en
otros
este arsenal legislativo será presentado
en el parlamento antes del final de año
mucha gente nos dice que debemos hacer
esto hace mucho tiempo que ya es tarde y
que tenemos que acelerar el proceso a
pesar de estas tensiones sudáfrica sigue
siendo común eldorado para sus vecinos
en robertson un enfrentamiento entre su
tos y simba wences dejó 17 heridos en
marzo pasado eran inmigrantes que se
peleaban por trabajar en los campos para
ganar 10 euros al día la calma regresó
pero estos refugiados económicos
aseguran que no tienen otro lugar a
donde ir
honestamente es difícil pensar que vamos
a regresar en zimbabue no hay nada no
hay trabajo nada que nos permita poner
al
con una tasa de desempleo que rodea el
35% la situación social en sudáfrica es
tensa y los discursos populistas de los
simpatizantes de la operación de tula no
hacen más que avivar el fuego
[Música]